لا لا لن يعود الى الوسيل مره اخرى راح
يلعب مع المنتخب المكسيكي ويلعب مع
المنتخب الهولندي في ملاعب مختلفه وسيظل
هذا الجمهور العظيم الذي زفه منتخبه
لتحقيق هلا نقاط راح يظل في الدوحه ويساند
المنتخب حتى ان شاء الله يتحقق الحلم
بالتاهل ان شاء الله مره اخرى للمرحله
القادمه وهو شيء الان اصبح قريب واصبح ان
شاء الله مضاعف بعد الفوز على المنتخب
الارجنتيني يعني ايضا هذا الفوز جدا ملفت
في ظل انتم الارجنتين كانت من الدول
المرشحه لفوز كاس العالم فهد
طبعا طبعا هو من الدول الثلاثه المرشحه
لتحقيق كاس العالم يعني
وخصوصا انه تقدم الشوط الاول لان ماني
الشوط الاول كان عكس عكس التوقعات يعني
المنتخب السعودي ما ظهر جيدا لكن الشوط
الثاني شوط المدربين ايضا تغييرات وايضا
كان فيه اا قتال من اللاعب السعودي شوفنا
القتال حتى اخر دقيقه يعني مهو ال 11 بس
اللي داخل المباراه حتى البدلاء اللي همم
داخل المباراه هيثم عسيري عبد الاله
العمري يعني كانوا على قد المستوى وحققه
فوز ان شاء الله راح يكون دافع المنتخب
السعودي على فريق كبير زي ما ذكرتي
المنتخب الارجنتيني بقياده ليونيل ميسي
ماذا عن يعني المنتخب هو وتشكيل المنتخب
هل هذه التشكيله
يعني كانت متوقعه من المنتخب السعودي ماذا
لديك من معلومات حول التدريبات اللي ااه
كانت للمنتخب قبل هذه المباراه
اخذ المنتخب السعودي كانت امام كرواتيا
كانت التغيير فقط تبديل المدافع الدلال
العامري بدخول حسان تمبكتي هذا كان
التغيير الوحيد لكن من خلال المباراه
اصابه الكابتن سلمان الفرج دخول نواف
العابد كان في حركه اكثر وايضا همم بعد
تسجل الهدفين كان في تغيرات ايجابيه من
هرفي رونالد
الجهه اليمنى المنتخب السعودي والدخول
سلطان الغنام وقف الجهه اليسرى اليسرى
تماما للمنتخب الارجنتيني تدريبات المنتخب
راح تتواصل ان شاء الله غدا مباراه
القادمه قريبه جدا الحمد لله فوز جميل
ولكن يعني اللي عكره شويه اصابه ياسر
الشهراني اللي ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
تكون بسيطه ويعود ياسر ان شاء الله لتمثيل
الاخضر مع بقيه زملاء وتحقيق ان شاء الله
الفوز واعلان التاهل او التعادل ان شاء
الله او الى التاهل في المباراه القادمه
الاخضر السعودي اول المتاهلين والمنتخب
السعودي
دائما مباراه المقبله ولا تعادل يكفي
للتاهل نعم نعم
لن يحسم حتى لو تعادل لن يحسم للمنتخب
السعودي لكن الفوز سيحسن نهائيا بطاقه
الصعود للمنتخب السعودي لكن التعادل لا لن
تبقى الكره لا زالت ملعب وهذه المباراه
الاولى لمجموعه المنتخب السعودي والمنتخب
الارجنتيني لا زال مشوار طويل اتمنى ان
شاء الله انه المنتخب السعودي يكون في
الدور 16 باذن الله تعالى